los rojillos son una minoría étnica
musulmana que vive que vivía en esta
hora acá en un estado dentro mi agua y
que a partir del 1982 se le quitó la
ciudadanía es decir no perteneciera al
país no pertenecían a ningún país una
minoría patria y a partir de 2015
aproximadamente comienza una persecución
del ejército que en 2017 hace cinco años
culmina con esta limpieza étnica que
denunció a las naciones unidas y con la
huida desesperada de los hinchas de
mianmar bangladesh a un campo de
refugiados donde se encuentran ahora en
condiciones tremendos y la acogida o la
llegada de estos refugiados a bangladesh
responde a motivos políticos y
humanitarios o forman también los
rohingya parte de la historia del país
vecino
bueno la noticia forman parte de ambos
países
digamos no pero que si los acusa se les
acusa en mianmar de ser nacionales de
bangladesh y por lo tanto
ciertamente tienen vínculos con con
bangladesh de hecho por su idioma por su
origen
histórico entonces a nueve de los recibe
pero es son un millón de personas en
situaciones muy precarias en un campo de
refugiados donde no tienen las las
condiciones mínimas donde se llevan
cinco años donde hay un gran número de
niños y mujeres que son más la mitad de
la población entonces realmente
digamos la red ucraniana y otros sucesos
se han tapado un poco la noticia de
bangladesh y sus provincias pero yo creo
que es es algo que la comunidad no se
llegue a prestarle nuestra atención si y
tras el golpe militar en myanmar ve
usted posible una vuelta de los rohingya
al país o la solución a la crisis
humanitaria todavía está lejos de
aclararse
no no hay ninguna posibilidad a corto
plazo los militares son los responsables
de haberlo echado del país y van a no
sólo los hinchas tienen tienen problemas
que en mier mar los que quedan sino el
resto de las etnias no soy la
persecución en mi contra todo aquel que
está en disidencia con el gobierno que
no es parte del oficialismo y hoy me
amar es una dictadura tremenda para
cualquier ciudadano de la etnia que sea
así que no creo que esa posibilidad es
mientras esté la dictadura militar es el
gobierno de que pueda volver a amar y
para acabar brevemente centrémonos en la
situación de los rohingyas en bangladesh
cómo es y qué soluciones podrían darse
para mejorarla
hace pocos días estuvo ahí la alta
comisionada de derechos humanos michelle
bachelet para inspeccionar la situación
y bueno no no digo muchas noticias es un
es un espacio muy grande muy costoso en
este momento
también en un proceso electoral en el
cual las minorías rojizas están siendo
acusadas por algunos hechos de
delincuencia y en el comercio discurso
también medio xenófobo alberto sobre eso
pero no queda claro que va a ser la onu
y la comunidad internacional para
resolver un problema de 75 años y que
afecta a un millón de personas